[Musique]
cette semaine je pense que le sujet de
conversation ce sont les feux de forêt
qui se passent pas seulement au Québec
mais un peu partout au Canada on voit
l'impact des feux de forêts on voit
qu'il y a des communautés qui ont été
rasées il y en a qui sont déplacés à
cause des feux de la fumée
par exemple présentement je pense
beaucoup à maloténome qui a été déplacé
qui va pouvoir bientôt retrouver
justement le chemin de la maison mais là
on pense aussi aux communautés qui vont
être déplacés donc les impacts des feux
de forêt sur les communautés il y a
beaucoup d'enjeux dans lesquels je
voudrais avoir une discussion pas
seulement d'avoir mais c'est la faute à
qui pourquoi est-ce que c'est là pas
assez de neige en hiver un printemps
très sec la déforestation pas assez de
d'interaction humaine parce que je pense
beaucoup au feu de forêt contrôlés qui
font partie des savoirs Ancestra
autochton et que ces interactions là
avec le territoire qui permettait
justement de diminuer l'impact des feux
de forêt
si c'est une des feux qui sont naturels
ou pas naturels parce que oui ils
peuvent être provoqués par la faute mais
être amplifiée par l'action humaine donc
toutes ces enjeux là c'est certain que
c'est des sujets qui m'intéressent mais
pour cette semaine pour ma chronique une
des enjeux duquel je voudrais parler
c'est un qui m'a vraiment beaucoup
frappé c'est celui de la justice
climatique mais aussi je dirais des
traces qui sont
très présentes dans mon esprit
de nos relations du passé fait que là je
pense beaucoup à ma luttena parce que
c'est l'exemple que j'ai pu voir j'en
vois d'autres dans l'Ouest mais j'ai pas
encore vu la suite justement des impacts
des feux de forêt mais je pensais
beaucoup au fait que quand Malo Téna
était annoncé pour être probablement
déplacé jusqu'à ce qu'il soit déplacé
justement de leur communauté
la communauté sort c'est la communauté
de pessamith parce qu'on pense on pense
aussi à titre mais comme elle est un
petit peu hors d'atteinte à cause des
enjeux du pont tous zen le pont qui est
achèterait qui bloque un peu la côte Est
là je vois que on se tente vers ce que
ça va être accessible mais je me suis
dit ouais mais
pour Cartier
là sont aussi accessibles et beaucoup
plus proches que puissamique qui est à
300 km 3 heures de route mais pour moi
ce qui m'a marqué c'est pas parce que
cette scène était pas prêt à accueillir
un action tu sais ils étaient prêtes et
je pense qu'ils auraient très
volontairement accueilli les personnes
qui s'étaient déplacées mais la relation
qui a été bâti au cours des dernières
décennies du dernier siècle c'est
vraiment avec de communauté communauté
c'est de réserves en réserve donc le
premier réflexe a été la communauté
depuis ce mythe de se mobiliser de
préparer à accueillir les gens de
maillot de Nam
et moi ça m'a dit ah il reste des traces
de cette ségrégation qui existait il y a
pas si longtemps entre nos communautés
le fait qu'on s'organisait entre nous
qu'on évitait justement de se mettre
peut-être des fois en danger face à la
discrimination face à du racisme et
pourquoi je pense à ça c'est parce que
dans dans l'ouest du pays excusez-moi et
dans l'est aussi parce que je pense à au
maritimes le premier réflexe est-ce que
c'est de se tourner vers nos voisins
parce qu'on n'a pas parti une relation
aussi facile
elle est en réconciliation elle est en
réparation mais on n'a pas bâti cette
relation là nos familles sont d'une
communauté à l'autre et pas d'une de nos
voisins à nos voisins donc c'est fou de
voir encore ces traces de ségrégation là
dans le construit
le construit la réaction face au
changement climatique face aux
catastrophes naturelles
et ça me fait penser beaucoup à l'ouest
je me suis dit est-ce que les
communautés aussi se sont en sécurité
d'aller voir leurs voisins je pense à
beaucoup de communautés que je ne
nommerai pas
il y a des relations extrêmement
problématiques avec les leurs voisins à
l'octobre le présentement je pense aux
algés qui vont être aussi en déplacement
on pense à des villes est-ce que on va
voir une différence entre
les services qui vont être offerts à des
évacuer à l'automne et les évacuer
autochtones parce qu'en plus quand on va
parler de reconstruction des
infrastructures je pense qu'il y a des
villages dans l'Ouest canadien qui ont
été complètement rasés par les flammes
mais nous ici on part quand même
beaucoup au niveau des infrastructures
qui sont sur le territoire dans la forêt
les chalets les cabanes en bois rond les
sites de camping mais les sites aussi
traditionnels fait que tout ça comment
ça va être reconstruit quand notre
économie est même pas la même quand le
financement des municipalités c'est pas
le financement sur les réserves qui sont
sous la Loi sur les Indiens donc toutes
ces en sont des enjeux de justice
climatique qui vont toucher les membres
des communautés qui vont être victimes
du déplacement puis aussi comment on
finance les déplacements est-ce que
comme par exemple dans certains des
déplacements qui avaient été faits parce
qu'il y avait eu des inondations à
territoire est-ce que les familles vont
se retrouver à du thème éternel dans des
hôtels on sait pas donc c'est des choses
qui font que je me dis faut qu'on se
tourne vers une accélération de
réconciliation une accélération aussi de
la solidarité avec les communautés qui
sont déplacées mais aussi des
communautés qui sont touchées aussi
qu'elles vont retourner chez elle
comment on va les aider à réparer ou à
défaire les impacts des feux de forêts
puis aussi
qu'est-ce que ça va être dans le futur
est-ce qu'on va instaurer un système qui
va nous permettre de réagir ah oui c'est
des événements naturels mais des
événements naturels qui vont des fois
être amplifiés par les actions humaines
par les choix que les humains vont en
fait sur leur propre territoire donc
comment est-ce qu'on va guérir justement
la forêt pour essayer de faire en sorte
que les communautés les villes les
villages soient pas affectés à chaque
fois de façon répétitive par les enjeux
des changements climatiques par les feux
de forêt par la sécheresse par la
disparition des des la biodiversité
c'est des enjeux je pense que ça
viennent puis qui vont nous toucher
parce qu'on le voit maintenant en vrai
donc j'appelle des gens à être solidaire
avec leurs voisins ouvrir leurs portes
ouvrir leur chalet à ceux qui pourraient
en avoir besoin parce qu'ils sont en
déplacement non choisi mais aussi de se
rendre compte que l'impact va pas être
seulement sur le coup ça va être aussi
du long terme et comment est-ce qu'on va
se reconstruire pour dire qu'on est dans
une province dans un pays qui est
réconcilié et qui n'est pas une perpétue
pas excusez-moi les injustices qui vont
être en plus amplifiées par les
changements climatiques donc j'espère
que vous êtes prêts à la conversation
j'espère que ça vous intéresse comme
sujet parce que je pense que c'est
d'avenir et ça va nous permettre de
pouvoir discuter du retour et savoir
ancestraux qui était justement
dans l'implication de l'humain dans son
milieu et non pas juste de le voir comme
un milieu qui est détaché nous on est au
coeur je pense que Montréal on le voit
présentant avec la fumée qui sera
jusqu'à nous on est au cœur de cette
situation là on est tous pris dans une
grande forêt tous ensemble donc comment
est-ce qu'on va céder les uns les autres
ça va être vraiment très parlant pour
nous en tant que société alors je vous
souhaite une belle semaine hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo et à nous envoyer
des questions